وينضم إلي الآن دون أنجيلا
المتحدث الرسمي باسم اليونيسف في تشاد، شكرًا
جزيلاً لوجودكم هنا معنا أولاً،
أريد فقط أن أبدأ
بما رأيناه للتو هناك
رد فعلك على هذا الاكتشاف المروع الجديد،
حسنًا، أنت تعرف ما الذي نفعله  لقد رأيت
هنا
على الجانب الشاتيان من الحدود
العشرات والعشرات والمئات من
الأشخاص يأتون كل يوم اه من
الجانب الآخر من مقاطعة دافو وأه
القصص التي يروونها
مروعة للغاية
لقد التقيت بشخص  امرأة أول
أمس وكانت تبلغ من العمر 28
عامًا وهي حامل في شهرها السادس ولديها ثلاثة
أطفال وكانت تجلس هناك في
هذه الجارة في هذه المدينة الحدودية
وأخبرتني كيف اضطرت إلى الفرار
وجانينا المدينة الرئيسية في دافو وهي  آه،
على بعد 30 كيلومترًا، أي 50 ميلًا و18
ميلًا سيرًا على الأقدام، وأخبرتني أنها اضطرت إلى الذهاب إلى
منزلها وقد احترق ولم يتمكنوا من
أخذ أي شيء، ولم
تسمع منه أي شيء عن زوجها وأخبرتني كيف
اضطرت إلى الركض دون الحاجة إلى ذلك.  قامت
بربط طفليها الصغيرين اللذين يبلغان من
العمر عامين على ظهرها، وكان على الطفل البالغ من العمر
خمس سنوات والطفل البالغ من العمر سبع سنوات
السير حافي القدمين مسافة 30 كيلومترًا للوصول
إلى تشاد وأخبرتني كيف رأت
جثثها  الجيران منتشرون في
الشارع أثناء فرارها،
إنه أمر لا يصدق وكما
سمعنا للتو في وقت سابق أه كانت الأمم المتحدة تتحدث
عن كيفية وجود زيادة كبيرة
في العنف الجنسي المرتكب ضد
الأشخاص تمامًا مثل هؤلاء النساء
والأطفال الذين أجبروا على الفرار من
منازلهم  المنازل
أيضًا، كما تعلمون، ما يقرب من 90 بالمائة من
الأشخاص الذين يعبرون هنا للدردشة هم من
النساء والأطفال الذين يصلون إلى هنا وهم
متعبون للغاية، إنهم في
حالة سيئة للغاية، معظمهم ليس لديهم
أي شيء بالأمس كنت على الحدود
ورأيت امرأة عجوز تُحمل في
عربة يدوية أه يدفعها أشخاص آخرون، إنه أمر
صعب حقًا ونحن
قلقون للغاية على مصير
الأطفال هنا
لأنك تعلم أنهم كانوا في حالة حرب لمدة
شهرين تقريبًا  هناك في المنزل في
الظلام الرابع ولذلك عندما يأتون إلى هنا
يكونون في حالة صعبة للغاية،
لدينا
سوء تغذية يتصاعد بشدة
ونحن حاليًا قلقون جدًا
بشأن صحة
الأطفال أولاً ولكن أيضًا بشأن صحتهم  -
وبصراحة، الأطفال الذين كنت أتحدث إليهم
رأوا ما لا ينبغي لأي إنسان أن
يراه،
شكرًا لك